attention pas ni d'une grosse claque
derrière non alors attendez c'est
d'autres caméraman qu'avoir un petit
souci fanny j'ai toujours là mais on
fonctionne il m'attendait à la douche
attente c'est vivifiant aux fans et je
m'attendais à la douche le matin et ça
réveille un franchement ça réveille
bonjour je connais pas cette fille je ne
sais pas qui c'est je crois qu'avec ça
je suis bonne pour me faire tous les
bêtisiers jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
c'était il n'ya pas si longtemps
finalement c'était en février dernier à
saint malo à l'occasion des grandes
marées en direct à la télé et je dois
vous avouer que ce jour là je me suis
senti ridicule mais alors complètement
ridicule mais figurez-vous bizarrement
je me suis pas forcément sentir ridicule
face à la caméra
ce jour là je me suis senti ridicule
plus tôt face à la nature face à la
force des éléments face à la puissance
de l'eau je ne savais déjà auparavant
mais ce jour là je crois que j'en ai
vraiment fait l'expérience et les frais
aussi parce que ça fait super mal face à
la nature
nous ne sommes rien nous sommes
ridicules nous humains et pourtant on
doit bien l'admettre et s'en rendre
compte
nous sommes devenus une force qui
influence sur cette planète la vie sur
la terre elle est possible qu'à travers
des grands mécanismes en général très
fragile et subtile et un de ces
mécanismes qui s'appelle l'effet de
serre je vais tout de suite cassé une
fausse idée sur le sujet
malgré tout le mal que l'on peut dire de
lui l'effet de serre est bénéfique
enfin je vous jure il s'est fait rêver
nefic
il est même plus que bénéfique l'effet
de serre est indispensable à la vie
s'il n'y avait pas d' effet de serre sur
la planète la température moyenne
mondiale elle serait comprise entre - 16
et moins 18 degrés autant dire qu'il ya
des endroit sur terre où on ne pourrait
même pas vivre à cause du grand froid
l'effet de serre est indispensable à la
vie
alors tout part du soleil évidemment le
soleil qui aimait de l'énergie et comme
la terre n est pas parfaitement noire
elle en absorbe c'est vrai une partie
mais le reste elle le rejette sous forme
de rayonnement infrarouge retour vers
l'envoyeur direction l'espace et c'est
là où le mécanisme de l'effet de serre
va rentrer en jeu il va venir bloquer
cette chaleur pour ne pas qu'il fasse
complètement froid sur terre et pour
qu'il y ait cet effet de serre il faut
qu'il y ait des petites molécules en
suspension c'est le gaz c'est le gaz à
effet de serre en faire un petit quizz
est ce que vous savez quel est le
principal gaz à effet de serre qu'il ya
dans l'atmosphère savez le choix 4
réponses on va faire un vote à main
levée ce sera simple comme ça
première réponse le méthane est ce que
quelqu'un dans la salle pour ce que
c'est le méthane le principal gaz à
effet de serre pas beaucoup de monde ça
doit être ça deuxième le choix de
réponses
la vapeur d'eau pourquoi pas oui
pourquoi pas la vapeur d'eau ya aussi le
co2 le fameux dioxyde de carbone co2 à à
à 1
peut-être le co2 est la réponse des uns
la réponse des sas et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont pas envie de répondre ou
c'est pour les climato sceptiques je
passe il y en a dans la salle
contre toute attente c'est la bonne
réponse c'est la réponse b la vapeur
d'eau est un gros piège
le principal gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère il est naturel c'est la
vapeur d'eau si elle pas de vapeur d'eau
sur la planète
il y aurait pas grand chose il n'y
aurait pas de météo et encore moins de
climat y aurait pas de nuages n'y aurait
pas de pluie y aurait pas des jurés pas
typhon n'y aurait pas de cyclos n'y
aurait pas de ragon lui rien absolument
rien du tout la vie elle est possible
sur la planète qu'à travers ce mécanisme
de l'effet de serre mais c'est un
mécanisme qui subit quand même quelques
variations ya 20 millions on était dans
une période glaciaire et le paysage que
l'on a aujourd'hui n'avaient rien à voir
rien avoir du tout avec le paysage
d'avant pour vous donner un exemple on
pouvait tranquillement aller à pied
jusqu en angleterre parce qu'à ce moment
là il y avait de la glace sur la mer du
or et sur la manche de la glace qui
arrivé jusqu'en france et même jusqu'au
sud de la france il y avait de la glace
jusqu'à marseille
j'ai un superbe exemple à vous donner il
s'agit d'une grotte elle est allée elle
est vraiment géniale cette grotte elle
est sensationnel une grotte qui aurait
pu être aussi célèbre que celle de
lascaux seulement pour y aller c'est un
peu compliqué il faut passer sous l'eau
dans les calanques de marseille
et quand on arrive dans cette grotte
dans cette cavité mais on voit que les
hommes y ont peint sur les parois le
monde qui était le leur il ya très
longtemps
il ya des milliers d'années et va sur le
mur et ils n'ont pas pas des bisons ils
ont peint des pingouins à ce moment là
il y avait des pingouins marseillais
ouais non c'est vrai il a seulement
fallu que la température moyenne
mondiale augmente de 5 petits degrés
pour que toute cette glace fonde pour
que les océans augmente leur niveau de
120 m et pour que toutes les moyennes
latitudes deviennent cultivables
comprenez bien que quand on augmente le
thermostat de 2,3 degrés c'est pas rien
du tout 2° et 3° même un degré ça change
tout absolument tout 5° cinq petits
degrés c'est ce qui nous sépare d'une
glaciation
alors bien sûr il ya des six
le climat change tout le temps des
périodes glaciaires et interglaciaires
déglaciation glaciation tantôt du
réchauffement du refroidissement
ça change tout le temps le climat a
toujours changé à travers les âges
c'est en fonction de paramètres
astronomiques le la terre n est pas
toujours situé au même endroit sur
l'ellipse et forcément de temps en temps
elle est un petit peu plus loin du
soleil et c'est ce qui détermine ses
cycles du climat le climat n'a pas
attendu l'homme pour changer seulement
ça a pris du temps
ça prend des milliers d'années ces
changements orna on a un gros problème
un super gros problèmes depuis quelques
décennies depuis l'ère industrielle en
fait la machine climatique s'est emballé
ouais on rythme hallucinant d'un dixième
de degré par décennie
on se remémore on a pris 5 degrés en
vingt mille ans et là on a quasiment
gagné 1 degré
en un siècle on change d'échelle et déjà
19 cm supplémentaires pour le niveau des
océans
y a plus vraiment de débat sur la
question
l'homme est responsable plus débat alors
par nos activités industrielles on
rejette tout un tas de choses dans
l'atmosphère et c'est là où j'en reviens
à notre mécanisme de l'effet de serre il
ya déjà beaucoup de vapeur d'eau
naturellement par nos activités
industrielles on va en rajouter encore
un petit peu plus mais c'est pas
vraiment ça qui influe le climat c'est
d'autres gaz comme le co2 le dioxyde de
carbone
il est très vicieux celui là très très
pervers l'eau dioxyde de carbone parce
qu'en fait il va rester longtemps dans
l'atmosphère il un fort pouvoir
réchauffant et surtout une inertie très
forte ce que l'on aimé aujourd'hui mais
on va le retrouver encore dans plusieurs
décennies ce que l'on aimé aujourd'hui
en 2050 ce sera toujours dans
l'atmosphère c'est bien ça le problème
yann images allait elle et elle est très
très jolies images de la nasa
elle est très très belle quand on sait
pas ce que c'est on pourrait presque
trouvé ça artistique
en fait non ça c'est ce que vous voyez
en rouge cesser la pollution c'est la
nasa qui a modélisé le cycle du carbone
avec les différentes sources d'émission
il ya les états unis l'europe surtout
l'asie et tout ça va tournoyer dans
l'atmosphère pendant des dizaines
d'années un vrai effet cocotte minute
alors ça marche pareil important
d'autres pas de gazon ça marche pareil
pour le protoxyde d azote le méthane
évidemment le fluor en appelant on
rejette plein de choses dans
l'atmosphère un vrai effet
cocotte-minute d'ailleurs cette image
cette métaphore à elle et elle est pas
mal elle est assez parlante faut bien
avoir à l'esprit vous pouvez vous
imaginer le soleil comme étant la flamme
la cocotte minute en fait c'est notre
terre c'est c'est l'atmosphère c'est un
peu tout ça la grosse cocotte minute et
puisqu'à l'intérieur c'est le gaz c'est
ce qui va venir booster amplifié et
activer ce réchauffement et la terre se
réchauffe
de plus en plus et on n'a pas l'air
d'avoir envie de couper le gaz c'est pas
dans nos plans apparemment en tout cas
c'est parce qu'on fait quand on va
puiser dans nos ressources d'énergies
fossiles ou pire encore quand on fait de
la prospection pour découvrir d'autres
gisements d'hydrocarbures qu'on n'a pas
vraiment l'air d'avoir envie de couper
le gaz et la terre se réchauffe
mais cette chaleur elle va pas
exactement dans monde pense là aussi il
ya une autre fausse idée sur la question
toute cette chaleur elle n'est pas
emmagasiner dans l'atmosphère mais dans
les océans
oui dans les océans se sont or le vrai
radiateur du monde à 90% cette chaleur
va se stocker ici ce sont eux les mers
et les océans qui pilotent véritablement
la machine climatique
faut vous imaginer la surface liquide
c'est 70% de la surface de la planète et
vous multipliez ça par 4000 mètres de
fond aux moyennes ça fait un réservoir
de chaleur absolument gigantesque est le
point de départ des phénomènes météo
climatiques violents
si la chaleur contenue dans les océans
c'est là où je remets ma main la petite
casquette de présentatrice météo pour
vous dire que des bêtes comme à yann aux
philippines ou encore catherine incendie
etc
aux etats unis ils viennent tous puiser
leur énergie dans la chaleur contenue
dans les océans ça se passe au niveau de
la bande équatoriale il faut que la
température dépasse un seuil critique
dans moyenne 26 degrés sur 50 mètres de
profondeur et voilà le point de départ
de ces monstres et plus les océans se
réchauffent forcément plus on doit
s'attendre à une recrudescence de ces
phénomènes violents
il ya aussi les vagues de chaleur les
canicules qui atteste de ce changement
brusque du climat alors pour être
pertinente ça c'est sûr il faut le dire
les données climatiques faut les
analyser sur au moins 30 ans ben
justement quand on regarde dans le rétro
la courbe elle grimpe la courbe de
température moyenne mondiale grimpe
si l'on regarde les dix dernières années
les plus chaudes depuis le début des
relevés thermométrique ces dix années
les plus chaudes se situent toutes au
21ème siècle sans exception un vrai
effet d'emballement avec deux superbes
exemples très proche de nous 2014 et
il ya quelques mois des records
pulvérisés partout à travers le monde
canicule spectaculaire par son intensité
sa précocité en espagne on l'a vu en
france haussier en juin dernier en
egypte en israël au pakistan
canicule meurtrière en inde et de
l'autre côté de la planète la californie
par exemple est en train de devenir une
terre complètement aride avec des feux
qui prennent en ce moment de tous les
côtés alors ces vagues de chaleur c'est
canicule quand ça s'installe sacré quoi
ça crée de la sécheresse une menace pour
l'agriculture
une menace directe pour les populations
une menace pour la stabilité
géopolitique et on définitif film menace
pour la paix et on n'est pas tous
vulnérables de la même manière face à
ces changements climatiques qui
surviennent je pense par exemple aux
petites îles plates du pacifique qui
elles sont en première ligne face à la
montée des eaux est là en ce moment
c'est petit état ils sont pas en train
de réfléchir à un plan d'adaptation
futur mais un plan d'évacuation mais
clairement ces petites îles de toute
façon sont condamnés à disparaître et il
ya une image qui enfin moi je la trouve
affreuse vraiment je la trouve
absolument abominable
c'est une image qui pourrait d'ailleurs
devenir habituelles dans le futur il
s'agit de la plus grand
barrière au monde en barbelés et en
pierres une barrière qu'on place et des
indiens pour ne pas que les habitants du
bangladesh migrent au nord car ils
fuient leur littoral qui est constamment
impacté par les typhons il ya une phrase
de paul valéry que j'aime énormément et
pour moi là beaucoup de résonance
paul valéry grand poète qui a dit
attention l'homme s'est assez souvent ce
qu'il fait mais il ne sait pas ce que
fait ce qu'il fait dit autrement
l'homme croit pouvoir tout maîtriser
mais ils ignorent souvent les
conséquences de ses actes importants il
est temps de se bouger maintenant il est
temps d'agir et d'impacter positivement
notre nature 2° c'est notre objectif
ou plutôt c'est le seuil à ne pas
franchir 2 degrés c'est notre défi et
c'est surtout tout l'enjeu de la coop 21
la grande conférence sur le climat que
s'apprête à accueillir la france et
c'est dans pas très longtemps maintenant
c'est dans quelques semaines ça commence
à paris au bourget et ça commence le 30
novembre
alors bien sûr ces négociations celles à
faire de nos chefs d'état c'est la
sphère de nos dirigeants mais c'est
aussi notre problème à tous à chacun
d'entre nous vous tous dans cette salle
nous devons être convaincus et climato
conscient il n'y a plus le temps 2° pas
plus avant la fin du siècle
c'est justement ce qui nous laissera le
temps de nous adapter
ce qui nous permettra de nous affranchir
des conséquences climatiques les plus
graves
et c'est surtout ce qui nous permettra
de garder une certaine maîtrise sur
cette situation climatique face à la
nature on n'est rien on n'a rien du tout
on est absolument ridicule
et pourtant et paradoxalement nous
sommes capables de bouleverser les
grands équilibres qui permettent la vie
sur cette planète face à la nature on
n'est rien on est ridicule et pourtant
notre
pouvoir d'action il est immense et ça
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est une bonne
nouvelle c'est une superbe nouvelle
cette crise climatique c'est une
fabuleuse chance une chance de redonner
du sens au progrès à quoi ressemblera
notre monde notre société notre planète
dans quelques décennies et bien en
réalité c'est juste une question de
prise de conscience et de choix